every two minutes a child is diagnosed
with cancer st baldrick's foundation and
mcmullen's irish pub are trying to put a
stop to that they're raising money for
childhood cancer research and this is
the 16th year they're doing this braving
the shave uh brian and lynn mcmullen uh
thank you so much for being here and
brittany with the clippers so brian
you're braving the shave and this is
such an important cause to both of you
talk about how this all started
thank you again for having us here um
brian and i lost our second child to a
brain tumor when she was
she was diagnosed when she was one
and she was two and a half when she
passed away and um we had no idea that
we would ever end up doing something
like this but
somehow we have a pub we have a forum we
have people that have hair
it all made sense so
uh stem portraits was just a natural
next step for us because it's all about
research and uh research saves lives
cairo was actually misdiagnosed so uh
research would have made a huge impact
research has gone such a long way for
childhood cancer specifically my brother
is a leukemia survivor and so i know
that firsthand uh we are looking at
video of course of the event so they
stand on stage here at mcmullins which
is uh just right off the strip it's so
easy to get to right on flamingo
tropicana flamingo tropicana tropicana
see i want to mess that up and
it's so fun so it's happening saturday
what can people expect from the event
how can they get involved
please yes uh if you don't like crowds
go online please
www.simpledicks.org search mcmullins
and find megalon's irish pub team or
team cairo which is the team in cairo's
name that we have
so that's easy okay you can also um
there's a link on our website that'll
take you straight to um our live
streaming which we're streaming live
from 11 a.m oh that's a great day so if
you can't make it you can watch
and you can donate from there as well
okay or you can pop over anytime after
11am and join the crazy and just
experience the magic you can have your
hair dyed green britney and her team
will do anything that they that you want
to your hair if you don't want to shave
so there's options you've got options
and brittany you've been doing this 15
years i have been so you know what
you're doing hopefully
do we have a spot still that we need to
get here on brian's head i have to look
it's a tiny spot over here a tiny little
spot to cut the end now nate and sherry
brian loftus they're all going to be
there on saturday helping you guys kind
of kick off this big event as well as a
plenty of other famous faces that they
may recognize very very fortunate to
have this incredible community behind us
we are very grateful wonderful because
that helps us thank you the money goes
to research we love we love we love
saint paul drinks and mick mullins of if
you haven't eaten there by the way it
has incredible food uh brian how's it
feeling
i feel relieved
oh look at that it feels nice and soft
see folks you want to do that you want
to do that to your head okay guys thank
you so much for being here this morning
go check them out you can do it online
remember or you can actually go to the
event happening this saturday we'll be
right back weather and traffic coming
right up thank you